hey guys today we're going to look at
some c plus inheritance and the basics
and some general things about how it
works this is not going to be all
inclusive i will reference some
documentation where you can look further
if you want to see more concepts
but after watching this you should be
able to understand
the general concept and work it as you
need to
for your particular project so we're
going to start with a visual studio
and we're just going to create an empty
project i want to use a cmake project
you don't have to
but i just want to kind of get used to
it so
we're just going to call this an error
demo there we go go ahead and create
that let it create
and we will get some basic files here
which we will go over briefly now note
that i did check
keep main project on the root level at
the bottom there
so i've got everything on the root level
in just one cmake that adds my
executable
so we're good to go here to start
programming the project is the point so
this kind of breaks
a little bit of what we were doing
before because before we're using the
terminal all the time
this time we're just going to let visual
studio handle some of that for us all
right very good so we got our header
here and we got a cpp that's just a mate
and if we go ahead and compile and run
then we should get a hello cma
telling us that it's all working now
what we want to do here is just add a
few new files we're going to go
add new file we're going to call this
one well let's think of an actual
scenario usually people just call it
base
and derive but let's think of a real
life scenario so that people can relate
it well we're going to call
this one v as a living being or maybe
we'll just call it
living being so we're going to kind of
use like an animals and a person type
example but this could be anything
say if you were doing furniture you
might have the very base b i don't know
like a dog living b
anyway we're going to make a living
being here and we're going to make this
header
pragma once pragma once because that's
good practice
and we're going to do class living b
and now what basically what we want this
class to encompass
is the things that all living beings
have and in our particular
thing we're going to say that all living
beings have hit points
because maybe we're playing a game or
something and you know maybe we can just
say
these are public for now let's not make
anything too confusing there's public
private and protected we'll get into
those later but we're going to start
with just leaving everything public
because that makes this the most simple
to explain and we don't have a
constructor here so everything is just
going to default construct
this should just be 0 initialized but we
can do that to make sure it initializes
so we don't really need an instantiation
class here but
for a file but we're going to put one in
here anyway new file
living being dot cpp and just include
clicking b and that way anything we
specify here
like this in particular has a place to
actually actually compile
okay very good now we can go back to our
h file and we're going to add this
living being and then our main here
which
is always going to have all the glued so
our whole project's going to keep you
piled up here as far as
includes but now we can do this and what
we can do here
is we can just take a look at this and
for example we can instantiate
a living being um i'll just call it lb
and i'll just say
they may be hit points now keep in mind
this has nothing to do here
we'll get there we'll get there of
course we can reference hit points here
because it's all public
all right very good so we'll hit play
here and now we got us a living being
with zero hp because that's what
initialized to
but say for example we want to say all
right i don't want users to be able to
instantiate this class i only want them
to be able to use it
to inherit from and they have to make
their own living beings and they can use
this to kind of help construct their
class
so they don't have to give every
creature they make hit points over and
over they can just say inherit from a
living being and we could add anything
anything in here too we could add like
hunger or
anything just fullness or needs food
or anything like that that a living
being might need
but to make sure that this doesn't just
get instantiated
or well maybe we'll say we have a name
here
so let's go string and we'll say species
name all right very good and i'll just
start as
something like unknown so maybe we don't
want to instantiate it with anything
maybe we also want to say
they have to pass in the species name so
we'll go actually we'll just go
on spare start here
vc's name all right very good and then
we'll make this
and then we can say species name oh we
gotta include string here
so it actually knows what we're talking
about species
name equals pc's name okay and now
we don't want to not be able to give it
a name we can just delete
the default constructor so now back to
our little demo here if we just try to
instantiate this without giving it
any of its constructor stuff it's going
to be a little confused because it says
hey there's deleted function
about uh the default constructor so what
we got to do is give it the actual name
here
let's call this one a fly
or maybe we'll say house black little
the common house fly
and now we can uh push out more info
here to our sea out
so lb dot species name hit play here
and we have now a little more info
living space name house fly hp
0 very good so that's
all about deleting a constructor there
now what if we still want to go further
with this and say
hey never instantiate one of these on
their own you have to make
something that inherits from living
being in that case we need some virtual
overrides because right now while you
can inherit from this it doesn't do a
whole lot special
so let's go ahead and just make a new
file and let's say
we want to make okay so living beings
let's say we're gonna make the human
type
all right let's just use that as a quick
example i'm sure most of you understand
humans or maybe you don't
we'll be honest i don't understand
humans all right pragma once
and we're gonna make a class called
human and then we're going to go
public living b it has to be public you
might think you can do private or
protected here but i'm pretty sure those
don't work
with inheritance for example if i go
private
it should result in some kind of
compiler error so i'm just going to
write the key words here
and if we don't want people to be able
to inherit from human we can declare
final and that means no further
inheritance as is allowed because you
can
chain inheritance for example you could
now make another
class that inherits from human and it
would have all the stuff from both
living being
and human and you get kind of a cascade
of effects that
can make a lot of sense in certain
hierarchies but here we go
so now in our demo we can say human
and now it's going to have a little bit
of an error here and
called human but we do got to include it
and we're going to include human here
so that it builds here and we got
included here
okay now when we compile this we should
get an error which you will see
shortly here and it'll say attempting to
reference a dereferenced function
it's because once again this is trying
to use the default constructor
but this one the one it said inheriting
from has a deleted default constructor
that's because we want to say no matter
what you have to specify a species name
anytime you're instantiating any sort of
human being
so you can do this and control how the
item is allowed to be created
compiler would just throw an error if
you don't specify the things
that you must specify so maybe we won't
hit points to be
1 starting out that would be fine
because 0 just seems to be low all right
so what we have to do is we may need to
make a human constructor
that also takes a const care star
species name
or we can make one make a human
constructor
and in it we can say all right let's
call
living being with the species type
human or i guess it would be like homo
sapien in this case
but you get to point let's uh let's go
ahead and go
include bean nobody knows we're talking
about there
and we of course we got to do this
public which is an example of private
not working there
and we still have one error attempting
to reference a deleted function
once again does not like this default
constructor
if he likes this no it doesn't it
doesn't like it
it's not going to like this because it's
deleted here on the base
so it's not going to be allowed here
either we do have to still go const
kerastar species so maybe this would be
better
as something else like a let's do a frog
i like the idea of doing a frog here and
now one thing that's really cool
something you may not know is that when
you're when you're doing this project
you'll notice as i'm adding stuff and
changing stuff
it is trying to keep up with the cmake
file by automatically changing these
names and everything
so rather than us having to switch back
to our cmake every time
when we create these new files using the
functions here but you can manually do
it if you're doing it in a different way
and if you need to correct it just go in
here and correct these names we're
keeping it super simple here and letting
it just be mostly default all right so
let's hit play
of course we don't have human anymore
it's now frog so we got to change that
and we still got the issue with the
human here it's now
frog broad this is going to be the
variable name
and we're still trying to use a default
construct that doesn't exist here so we
got to give it a type
let's say maybe tree a tree frog
as you can see it's still not too happy
and that's because we need to put this
function in here
so usually it's going to have a little
quick action that says
oh we got to correct this i think or
something here
all right well basically we want to make
this function over in the cpp
and we want to say living being we want
to call it space constructor
well we don't do that here you got to do
this in a special way put it in this
list over here
living being parentheses species type
whatever you're passing in here
then you can start brackets and boom
that will work
that'll now use the constructor and you
will get the right type
living bean species tree hp1
okay very good so what about this frog
type where did it go
well turns out you can access that as
well
if you're doing it in this particular
way you can also of course set anything
a frog might have
let's let's just add something to the
frog let's have a little fun here
say maybe privately it has um
float jumps out because it's a frog
and we will just by default initialize
this to
uh one point very good but now
when we go back here we can say see out
blue uh well we're typing living being
here
but let's be a little more
non-specific jump power now this one is
specific
frog frog dot jump now however it's not
seen in here because we made it private
so let's just bump that up the public
for the moment
make it make it simple and now we get
all those
except i did the formatting a lot
different on this jump power okay
so you might be wondering what is the
point of this there is a point of us
forcing
a constructor type whenever we're making
a certain type so anytime you're making
a living being it's going to force you
to give a name
you can make it have whatever you want
or need so if we look at more
modern apis sometimes they do stuff like
this and they have you
force maybe a struct that you have to
fill out
so maybe you have to fill out like
construct
details this is more relevant for things
that have special api
settings maybe or maybe
info so that way you have to instantiate
and fill out this truck first
and then pass it in so we could do
something like that
like we could have this have the
standard
string species name
and rather than this coming in here info
well we can make it constant it's fine
and we
go living info info
and we could say species name equals
info
dot species let's fill this out properly
there we go
and that way when you now make something
say a frog you can no longer pass this
tree
first you have to make a living being
info
this is kind of a weird thing you don't
see this too much we'll just call it
frog info but this could be handy if you
got a bunch of them and you don't want
to keep constructing
the info over and over now you could do
something like this
living being info frog info and then
we'll go
frog info dot button species name
equals uh well frog of course or no
we'll say tree and i will show you in a
moment here how to do even more so we're
gonna pass this info in here
and it should be happy was just not
happy
oh because we have to take it here as
well
living being info info let's stick with
our cons
you can also stick with a reference if
we want to make it a little more
efficient
so we're going to put the same thing in
the cpp file
and pass that over here now it should
construct properly
assuming we've filled everything out so
we need reference here
and reference here okay gone seared
and now this should work apparently we
made
an error here okay says frog illegal
member
initialization living being is not a
base member
okay did we get something wrong here
it's very possible we did
it's possible that it might not like the
reference let's dig in there's a lot of
things here
but it's probably just one very small
thing looks like it's not getting
created
how we want
so we should get living being info in
there
oh i need yeah one of these semicolons
at the end of the struct
that's important you get all kinds of
weird errors if you forget that and
there we go we have species it's tree
hit points jump power
now maybe we want to say that like how
do we know it's a frog sure we could
hold frog
for every frog or we could just get the
class name so i'm going to show you a
little trick there
to just spit out the class name so we
know it's a frog so we can go cl
and we can go type id
frog dot name and that will get us
this should say class frog there we go
type
class frog species tree hp1
now we can get a little trickier here
and go further
with the inheritance and say well
first of all this still allows just like
living beings to be instantiated
living well we'll just say being here
and we want a species name
and we'll call it asdf because this is
kind of a broken function or actually
you know that's right we take
living being info so let's pass in frog
info again
and there we go now we should be able to
spit all this info
about the b by just passing this in here
of course it's going to have the frog
info we could create an entire different
struct for it but i'm
just being lazy here so that's why i've
given it the same info here and you'll
see here it doesn't like jump power
naturally because it's behind in the
inheritance so we'll hit play here
there we go type living being it's got
everything else
but now what if we want to say look you
should never be able to instantiate it
being you got it
you got to inherit it somehow that's
when we come
to pure virtual now c plus doesn't have
the inheritance keyword
so what you have to do is use pure
virtual
and we can also do other things like
start keeping unique ids
because sometimes that is very important
in your software
so what if we also want to say that this
has
a unique id geek id and we'll just start
it out as zero but we know that anytime
this becomes instantiated
we want to have a new you can unique id
that's never been used before
i'm getting a little off track here i
just want to show you this unique id
thing
because it's pretty cool so what you can
do is you can make a static
and a cpp or here so this isn't visible
to really any
anywhere in our software static let's go
with unsigned
and unique id or we'll say total id
total unique
id counts so this particular
variable is only going to be accessible
here unless we do some extern magic and
other files
so we don't want to do that we want this
to stay only here and we're just going
to say anytime a living being is
instantiated
we're going to say that the unique id of
that being
is going to be equal to whatever our
total count is and then we're going to
plus it up so
this is a post increment
so we'll first gather this whatever this
is which should start at zero
let's go ahead and make sure it
initializes with that sort of thing
we'll actually even specifically put a
zero in here so the very first time this
is built
it's gonna initialize to zero the very
first one will grab zero
then after since this is a post
increment it will become
one and that way if we ever query for
total ids
we will get the correct amount it will
say one but the first one is going to
have to id
zero so a little bit of a programming
zero one trippiness there
but if you were to say plus plus on this
side
then it will increment first and give
the first item the id
of one hope that makes sense a little
post and pre
thing there that can can be very
relevant so let's go ahead and just show
that real quick
um we want to say now the id unique
id frog dot unique id
and indel and then we're going to look
at this living being unique id this this
plain one and i will break the speed in
a second and show you how to make it
non-substantiatable
and as you can see they know how unique
ideas the frog got zero
class got one so if we just change this
a little bit and pre
i'll just show you that it should do as
i explained
here we are starts at one and then goes
to two and so on so the great thing
about this is
if you ever need to find something you
can grab this id
and store it somewhere in your software
and be like okay keep track of this
object someday we need to find this id
something like that and if your program
is set to run for
a long time you may occasionally want to
purge and sync
and kind of go through your ids see
what's missing do it get a total count
reassign them you can do things like
that
but it's all going to be magically
contained within here
since this is a static declared in a cpp
file
we're not going to get into that but
that's a theory of a thing you can do
because of course unsigned end has a cap
number once you get to i don't know what
is it some billion
there we go there's the unsigned in max
so million billion yeah about 4 billion
so you
you'll have be able to have a maximum of
4 billion
290-something unique instances
which should be plenty but keep in mind
that if this goes past that it's going
to start over at zero again
so you probably want to have some logic
when you get close to this cap now
obviously you might think oh i'm never
going to get to that cap but when you're
in something that's just
running non-stop and it's always using
unique ids it can get to that
so you want to have some logic in here
this will say something like you've
reached the maximum number
or maybe you'll have a cleanup function
that takes some time to go through them
all and resort them out
and like figure out which numbers are
missing and you can essentially start to
do some sort of hashing with these ids
this is just a very simplistic example
hope that all makes sense
but it's very important to realize stuff
like that when you're programming or
you're going to run into strange bugs
okay so back to the pureversal thing i
was talking about
you basically want to put any kind of
function here that is purely
virtual so it needs to be virtual and
we've got to give it a name say we'll
call it
uh let me think of something here okay
well i was kind of thinking
you know every living being's got a
cycle of some sort that it goes through
for its life so we could put that
in here i'm going to call that just
update
and i'm going to set it equal to zero so
we now have a virtual oh
void it doesn't return anything but wait
update equals zero now what this
equals zero means is it means there's no
base version of it without the equal
zero
it's going to ask us to instantiate and
put our root
thing so it's a living being you're
going to have to if you're instantiating
one you're going to have to say
how it updates because the default is
well you don't know maybe it's like a
clam and it doesn't do anything but sit
there most of the time
and occasionally move or maybe it's
something more active like a frog where
it's going to scan its environment and
think about what it wants to do next so
this is where you could essentially for
this sort of example anyway put some
sort of logic but if you set it equal to
zero
then what you want to do is uh well
let's show this first now that it's
equal to zero
it's going to say yeah you're not
allowed to instantiate this
and if you hover over it it's going to
give you some info it's one of the great
things about using an editor like this
when you're new is you can get
some info right in line here and it'll
say it's an abstract class
has a pure virtual function so we can no
longer
do that and i'm not sure why it doesn't
like that oh it doesn't like frog now
so let's get rid of this one this one's
not going to work now you can no longer
instantiate living beings on their own
it's pure virtual
only for inheritance often called an
interface
class okay so now frog is
missing some stuff so basically we want
to implement the pure virtual functions
from anything
we are inheriting from so we're going to
do some quick refactoring and it does
have
visual studio has a nice little thing
here you can implement
and it says operation failed okay i
guess it doesn't work that well
so basically we want to take this and
paste it over here
this time without the equal zero this
time it
overwrite now i think override might be
optional here since uh it's
you have to overwrite it but now let's
go ahead and make this function
and it looks like it's seeing the frog
is not in the project for some reason
i don't know the visual studio helper
thing is messing up a little bit
so we're just going to add this as we
need maybe it doesn't like the word
override
let's check so you can kind of play
around here a little bit and sometimes
this will get you along but oftentimes
what you'll find out
is that you need the function signature
was okay that's
weird override okay let's put it right
back in there
doesn't seem to matter and there's
update it did
put it in i guess it just can't find
this file for some reason i'm not sure
why visual studio thing sometimes it
takes a little time for it to sort
itself out so now we can say what a frog
does on its update
and we might need more info like we
don't have any info about the world or
anything currently so we don't know what
a frog is doing
but we can assume that the frog is
growing
getting hit points sleeping or maybe
it's dead who knows who knows more
froggy
so we could do something like well every
update
let's get a status update and say like
if hit points
is uh less than zero
then we are going to set its hit points
to zero so we don't want to go into the
negatives
and maybe we want to do more stuff than
that too i guess it would be a less than
or equal to zero
so we don't want it to go into negative
hit points maybe you allow negative hit
points but
i'm in particular not allowing them so
if hit points is less than or equal to
zero well make sure it's exactly zero
and then we're going to do something
like
uh we could well this was going to
require us adding more functionality of
course
but we could say we could put it on a a
dead list
for example like the ford frog is is
dead
uh maybe we want to say we want to have
a status over here or maybe we know the
status based on hit points
so use your own discretion about what
you want to do here but
we could at least do that we could at
least make sure and maybe later
we want to check i guess this might be
this is kind of a weird thing to put
here to be honest but just with
the little amount of info we have i feel
like we're not going to
feel them too much so now what you want
to do
is you want to start some kind of loop
so say something like
while well this would be a game movement
theory frog.if points
is greater than zero well you want to
check it so
dot update and then we probably have
something like simulation.run
that takes in well simulation.update so
we in theory need some kind of
simulation for this
do-more but what this would do is it
would just sit here at this while loop
waiting for this frog to go to zero hit
points
so what we might want to do is apply
some logic there we could
we could do a lot of things we could
take in a few new functions
we could put some functions into our
interface class
like well first of all we have this info
that we're using for the struct
so maybe we want to start specifying
some default hit points
so we could do that we could go standard
or well int it points
or let's keep our syntax going hit
points
and we'll i guess that's it we just got
those two right now
and i'm going to show you a few more
things here shortly hope you're sticking
with this
learning something from this about
inheritance a bit and c plus plus a bit
okay so now we have another thing added
to that info that we could set
we can say hit points and
give it some hit points we'll say it
starts with
three hit blocks okay now when we hit
play we'll see that it's
hp still one oops okay so the problem
here is i believe
we haven't actually changed our
constructor we just haven't set it
here we haven't said it points
equals info dot
it once so a little bit of leg work but
what you can actually do here
is you can go further with it and you
could make this
even set its own struct to itself so
uh we could do something like okay well
we've got a living being info
now instead of keeping all these
individually we could just say
we have living being info and we connect
um
info let's just keep it that for now so
now in this constructor rather than
adding things to it every time
we can just say that info will be named
into capital info
equals info that will bring it in and it
should get all of those values
we got an error that doesn't like says
it doesn't have these that's because
they're now hidden between behind
the info struct which we'll just have to
add here
and it doesn't like it here of course
and it's still saying it doesn't have
hit points so let's keep digging in
info oh the hit points are lowercase now
we'll leave it like that
we just need to make sure we're calling
it correctly
species underscore name and hit
points and we might have one other
function but use your discretion
how you want to name your stuff i'm just
kind of winging it here of course this
one is now
info dot it points
it once very well there we got three hp
and it's waiting for updates so it's
just sitting in that while loop checking
the old thing
so that's a decent amount about this now
if you want to not not have this be an
interface all you got to do is remove
this zero
and give a base instantiation
so in theory we might want a base
instantiation of update let's just show
that real quick
uh maybe we want to say info dot we'll
do the hit point thing
like maybe we want to do that with
everything no matter what we always want
things we have some sort of hit points
so we have a default
instantiation of checking the hit points
and setting them to zero if they're
below zero
that way when we maybe check this at the
end of our main or end of a frame or
something
when we like maybe clean up all the
stuff that's dead or process an
animation of their dad or
a thing or some command maybe an audio
trigger
of a their sound we do that
but now we still have this update over
here
we've removed the stuff it should in
theory no longer be checking but you can
force it to check
by going living being update
and then it's going to call that base
class one and then whatever special
stuff you have for your class
now since we no longer have any pure
virtual functions
this can be substantiated on its own
again so you got to be careful about
that
there might be more or less you want to
do you kind of have to make the best
decision for what you're doing
but we could say here at this point that
hey frog frog is final if you're going
to use a frog you can't
inherit any further so you just have to
give it
the proper being info and you can use
that class type grabber to see
what kind of class it is class frog so
you can use that for
comparisons if you want to know if
they're the same type but it gets
trickier because you might be saying
okay well we're kind of going to know if
they're the same type
the same type right well well well this
is where things get
funny all right so say
forget about this frog for a second well
let's make yet another type of living
being and i'm going to show you some
more examples new file and
rather than frog this time we're going
to have a
cat let's do a let's do a lion like the
idea of making a lion
so pragma once last
lion with public living
being go and
public private so we don't actually need
to give it anything here
well other than this constructor right
here we have to give it this constructor
so that we can pass it along
so we'll put that in here but of course
flying
this time and we just need to
instantiate it oh we need to make that
file and file it dot
our line we gotta use quotes here
fill out this function doesn't know what
this info is so
yeah we do have to include the living
being class
which doesn't seem to want to do through
the helper just manually type it in here
and it should sort those out as soon as
it is happy enough to do so
you can always hit this pure virtuals if
you want to do the shortcut but there
are no pure virtuals
because our update is no longer virtual
but
you can go further you can have plenty
more functions as many as you need
and some of them might not ever have a
root case
so in that case you would start making
this a pure virtual
the way i'm kind of thinking about this
i would want this to be pure virtual
but maybe it's an unknown being so you
know maybe you don't want to have
a special one of these
okay so now at this point we would have
some other kind of living being
info let's do the lion info and we could
kind of hold
like the lion's stats here so to speak
and we'll just call this
a sahara i don't i don't know all the
line types
but let's say they start with uh 10 hit
points
all right cool so we'll make one i'm
just going to copy this i'm going to
change everything this is now going to
be
lion lion and lion info
lion put all that in there doesn't know
what lion is let's add it
here there we go now we should be able
to hit play looks like we have an
error let's take a look lions don't have
jump power
i guess in theory maybe we'll have
something else so we'll
give the lion something else like uh
maybe it has well frogs can't do much
but jump they don't have much of an
attack but lions definitely have an
attack and they have
potentially a bunch of stats other than
just hit points so maybe we'll have
a specific lion stat called like uh
byte power all right bike power however
you want to do it let's
do it like this case for now i've got
kind of a mix of these but
you know i'm kind of adjusting on the
fly here okay so
maybe we have bike power and we didn't
give it a
base so it should initialize to zero
should just say zero
and looks like we forgot to call the
living being function here in this
constructor
so we will do that living being past
that info and that's it
so you should get nice little warnings
and as you can see since we didn't
specify
the lion stuff it's got some weird weird
numbers um let's
make sure we instantiate those properly
and that should fix it oh we're setting
frog and photo different stuff so this
all needs to be line info
clearly so the default values it was
getting
for that struct was junk so that's
interesting if we don't want it to do
that you could put stuff like this
on these and they will default to
whatever
your compiler wants them to be looks
like our jump power is still very weird
so we want to go back to here oh we
haven't set it
that's why see uh with the frog do we
set the jump power
yeah it's got a default constructor on
this we don't we
maybe want to say there at least by
power of three
so that would give it the default and
there it is three
now if you don't want to give it the
default
all right you can still leave that there
but you could update it before you
actually use it
by just saying hey my lion so after
you've instantiated it you can go
lion.power equals whatever you might say
it's 10.
and let's give this frog some jump power
and we'll get more
good too so now we should see the
updated stuff
i forgot to update the uh text here
should say byte
for the lion there we go so now we have
some kind of basic stats that we can
pull from and do things with
because we also could put in here we
could put in some functions to
have these things take damage we could
say
for example virtual void take
damage or you know this could be
anything this could be like
maybe something the update will call and
if we want to say well let's
let's go with heat all right and we're
going to override this but when we eat
we're going to think about what kind of
properties do you need to know about
when you process and eat
right so maybe we'll have another struct
that we need to know about
it for every living being so we'll put
it here called uh
food info right we'll keep it really
simple you could have all kinds of
special foods and types and fill this
out
whatever you want but maybe we'll just
say like um floats
carbs all right well let's take
we'll stick with integers here so you
eat food it has some amount of carbs
or energy or something we'll call it
energy we'll just keep it super simple
so we could say by default maybe well
let's not make this pure virtual i don't
think it's going to
be necessary we could say by default it
points
plus equals energy so we could just
straight up heal from this
right but i guess it would you know we'd
have to have it in here maybe you'd have
something like uh well you need to pass
it let's do a pass here
so you pass in god well let's see
honest food info info we'll do that
so now in this function when you create
it let's get rid of the old one here
probably going to use the same thing we
can say
info dot hit points plus equals
f info dot energy lower case
okay so very good now whenever you
process an e it points to go up by
whatever
energy now you could of course if you're
not doing delta time you could do heals
over time and stuff with this
or do all sorts of interesting
processing
but the point is here say we've got well
this is hit points
we haven't specified max hit points
which obviously you'd want in this case
but for example let's just go lion dot
eat and we need some food info here so
we can go
info uh info maybe we could say
he's going to eat a piece of meat we'll
just we'll just call it meat info
and we'll just give me info dot energy a
value of
i believe i made these integers so we
might want to always use floats or
always use integers just depending on
how our
program is but now we can pass meat info
into here and he's going to eat that
and it's going to process so we should
see that he has the base hit points
of even higher because if we look at
this all right let's see what did we get
we gave it the base hit points of 10. so
after eating
something with energy of one should have
a base hit points
of 11. and which it's here let's go
ahead and
and there it is hblip all right now i
just want to show you one last thing
let's get pretty long there's like so
many things about this
don't worry i will drop resources here
in a second where you can learn more
about these i just wanted to show you
some
logical examples but i do have one more
important thing
to show you so maybe every frame we want
to do with these updates of course right
makes sense and maybe this food need
thing would happen somewhere as part of
your game
so in this line we do also want to make
sure
well we haven't specified our own
specific update
we don't actually need one here anymore
either since we're not doing anything
special
so we could get rid of that and it would
still call just fine because it's
inherited
through the living being here if this
were pure virtual once again you would
need to and yeah that's the only
difference with your virtual
there's more tricks to pure virtual than
i'm not mentioning i will say
all right so the final thing i want to
show you i want to show you that what if
people just want to like hold all of
these in an array
well they have one thing in common
that's that they're all
of the living being type frog lion
because for example
we could make a vector
of frogs but we can't put lions on there
but if we want to put like all animals
or all living beings on there we could
put this to make this vector religion
and we'll just call this uh all beings
and kind of keep track of all of them it
doesn't know what vector is
naturally we do have to include that so
we're going to go
vector in our header here and
i think we're going to hit play right
now but we're not using this all beans
yet it's just blank right
let's uh let's initialize it might as
well so rather than doing
all of this a bunch of different texts
this would actually work again right now
until we once we make it to the virtual
and it's got some errors on it though
but we'll just leave it we'll just
delete it
okay so what if you just want to be able
to like iterate through and call
all your stuff we need a different case
here really so let's just keep it going
um yeah i guess we could have
yeah we'll do while one because maybe
we'll have like a break
where we can get out of this if if
something specific happens so while one
is
is kind of okay as we'll see here
shortly
all right so very good so maybe you just
want to do all
things dot pushback and then we can do
log info
right then we can actually get rid of
all this and we can do the same thing
for our lion rather than instantiating a
line right here we could say
all beings push back line now also
these are going to stay to the end of
scope so it might actually make sense to
put them in
each in their own scope because you
don't necessarily want this struct to
sit around in memory once you've
populated the info
right so let it do its thing
and there we go so now what we can do
let's get rid of all this we haven't
messed with the byte power or anything
like that but you could
because you can go all beans the one
that just got pushed back would be
dot back and then we go dot e or
whatever we want give us some food info
there
let's do this one here let's make the
food info real quick
and we'll say eat give it meat info
and boom it'll have done it also the
same thing here for the frog if we want
to process anything before moving on
being stuck back and we could say
this is probably going to be an error i
think i actually meet in place back here
but we'll write it out and see what does
okay
what do we got we got some options here
we could have it
well you see the thing that's tricky
here is we're only getting the options
from the living being we're not getting
the frog info although it is a frog okay
so what actually we need to do here
is specify that we're creating a frog
this one specify that we're creating a
lion
in this one now we could we don't even
necessarily need to give these structs
different names now there are different
scopes
but should anyway just for shadowing to
avoid shadowing as much as possible
okay so now we'll have a frog here lying
here so this frog we should be able to
call
i don't know if the syntax has picked up
on this yet
but we should now be able to call the
frog info on this particular one
back dot what does frog have that we can
use
jump power so let's attempt even though
it doesn't say it
set jump power equal to 2 dot
f as you can see it doesn't like it so
let's hit play here
but we do know that we're pushing a frog
onto that
and now this is where we can get a
little tricky
frog undeclared oh we got some errors
here let's just get rid of that
let's just comment out this whole thing
i'll fix that up shortly
just don't want it to get in the way
but what we can do we can just go
through all these we can go for
each const auto by wrap
we don't want to change them we just
want to look at them here we're going to
say
lb which will be a living being out of
our all beings
or maybe we'll just call it a b keep it
super simple here
we could say i don't know let's just do
a little cl
uh basically all this info right why not
but now rather than doing this every
time we go
whatever the type of b is here and all
down the line just
all the b stuff it's not going to know
about jump power because we are once
again looking at all beans
so this is where it can get a little
tricky
but this is also where the interface
comes into play
as you can see now it is pretty much
working properly except the type
is living being no matter what it is so
how do we tell
which type it is with this sort of thing
well there might be some really fancy
way of doing it but one
really easy way to do it is to just turn
this back into a pure virtual and say
look you got to implement
your type name of some sort where you've
got it you've got to implement this
type name so in any of these we can
instantiate them by going into my pure
virtuals
and we're going to say well the line
type name is going to return
type id of itself might be star
this one of these i don't know we'll
find it here or actually i think i might
need to have
type info in here type info
or maybe we could just have it somewhere
else but we essentially
could override it yeah there we go and
let's see
if this works this might be a compiler
error but now when we call
type name we'll have to use our own
function rather than this
we'll go and type name and we pass in
itself
type name is unidentified oh it's b dot
type name i don't think we need to pass
anything there
this isn't going to work for all beans
necessarily because they're not all
instantiated
so we're going to have to add frog
implement pure virtuals
id and this dot name and i think we've
also got to add type info here so we
probably just want if you know you're
going to
do it the type input way you could just
add it to the living being
type info there might be a better way of
doing this
i'm sure there is but it involves a lot
more code so i'm kind of doing it in
like the least code amount of way and we
have some errors so we can say okay
what's the problem doesn't like the
pointer to this being a reference so i
think we just have to de-reference
on this this with star of this maybe
i think that's right
and it looks like it put these in
private they should not be private
that's just the way digital studio
decided to do it
so let's go like that and we still have
one little problem cannot convert this
pointer from
kant's living being to living being
reference
so the thing about starting to make one
thing pure virtual
is the whole class becomes pure virtual
so anything we previously instantiated
that we wanted to have default behavior
will no longer work so we do have to
make some choices here about how
we want to do this and i think kind of
the most obvious way with this type name
thing
is well we want to have a default
behavior
right so let's give it a default
behavior here and maybe we can just
return
the whole type id of itself and this
should probably be a string
let's see if that works or we could just
do encapsulated
string like that it's a bit ugly but we
will see if that works
as a default behavior so that if we
don't overwrite it
in these classes it should give us the
root type
all right everything looks good we have
the same thing let's see we still get
the root type
or if we get errors we get errors okay
so what do we get here
doesn't like this type name then i have
oh i need to
go we're not currently overwriting them
and now
builds and it looks like we get class
with a const pointer 64. which looks a
little weird
because we are not dereferencing this
so it is literally getting the pointer
to the class it's getting the type id of
the pointer so maybe we want to
de-reference
this which is just class and we should
get class b
so if we want to override this behavior
and each of these we can get there tight
so let's do that let's start with the
lion
and even the frog and we will override
this behavior
essentially doing the same thing well
let's see here
that one put this in here make sure we
have it declared here
and we'll do the same thing with frog
this line
and put this in here and now
what do you think is going to happen
when we go over all the beans and spit
out the type of
is it going to call the root class is it
going to or is it going to call the one
that we actually pushed back let's find
out
it looks like it calls the root plastil
so how do we get it to properly use this
override of the one we declared
because in theory it should be let's
take a look
this is an area where pointers can help
us out so instead of just
storing the objects of living beings
we're going to store
pointers to living beings so i've added
a star here and now when we push back a
new
type like the new frog here and then new
line here we want to make sure we use
the new keyword so that we're creating a
new object now keep in mind that you're
getting into memory management at this
point so that is something to consider
it might even be better to make these
some other kind of smart pointer if you
want but you'll have to do that at your
own discretion
we're going to kind of leave off about
here anyway because we're getting to the
end of the points all right so we push
back
pointers to our new objects and of
course when we call the back functions
that we were calling
before we need to use the pointer but
now you'll see
that we're now allowed to access well it
should access
jump power in the frog we have that
still yeah we have that here
oh let's go back here leaving bean has
no
okay so it's still seeing it there uh
interesting
i guess we have to do a slightly
different but you can see that when we
get a reference to it and do the type in
here it's now going to call
the class that as instantiated as and
not
the root class anymore so that is pretty
interesting
as you see we have to find some default
behavior here
because we kind of have to since this
isn't pure virtual
and and if we end up using it we can
just overwrite it
and call our own version of it and it's
going to call its own version of it
so this difference you basically just
need to store vector
pointers if you want to make sure you're
using the overridden
class which is kind of interesting if
you think about it
because maybe we want to override more
stuff like that function
we can and if this is not a vector of
pointers
or just override let's see how i had it
here
oh we need food info of course let's
just copy this whole thing over
now let's override so we have the full
behavior of course but maybe we want to
have lion behavior too where you check
the type of food you eat or something or
maybe
lions are super efficient at eating so
their hit points
is going to be bigger factor uh we need
info
dot hit points that's what it is right
just thinking for a minute
maybe we'll do like plus equals f info
parenthesis here because i'm going to do
a little math dot energy
or maybe they're less efficient so we
add to their hit points
the efficiency but only times uh
0.90 or something so maybe we could add
that to their points but
also we only want to add integers so we
want to
round this off so the easiest way to do
that
would be to static cast
do an integer and oh there we go
it's a little risky doing this whole
static cast thing this way but that just
says hey it's going to round it
basically and this is probably going to
round up
but if energy were huge it might cut off
a few ticks
so it can matter a little bit and there
we go we'll see that the lion didn't
actually end up gaining any hp because
it wasn't enough to get to
one i guess it's rounding down uh i
guess we
need some math functions this this might
always round down uh there's one way i
guess we could check
let's see we're given its energy one
what if we give it two then doesn't
round down to one and we end up with
eleven hit points yes
so that point 90 is going to round down
and there's a lot of little theory you
could bring in you could say hey man
what if we just want our points to be
floats instead so we can be more precise
or something like that or what if we
don't want to ever do this sort of
behavior in general maybe this is
something to avoid
maybe we could just do more flat out
bounce like
uh times two spell energy right there we
go
and that would give him what before his
points so you kind of just got to decide
on your types is the point there but i
think i've showed enough about
polymorphism and
well yeah i did end up talking about a
little bit of polymorphism this little
concept
here where we can instantiate
types with the subclass as pointers
is called polymorphism and there's more
about that all right i'm going to show
you some quick links about where you can
the best sources i think to learn more
about this okay bright screen
alert now first of all i will say that i
did do a fair amount of googling and
stack overflowing and stuff like that
just even in this
little project and that's always a thing
you're always going to need to look up
stuff unless you're like a master
and for something like c plus plus it
takes a really really really long time
or just a lot a lot a lot of practice to
get to master
so bright screen warning i'm going to be
bringing over a bright screen all right
sorry about your eyes this site ian.cpp
reference
is one of the best so we would just want
to look up
inheritance and we'll see inherited c
plus they've got a bit of a book intro
and you can learn
all about it here there's a lot of
examples i really like the site for
looking up stuff looks like they have
some
derived class info which will give you
even more info and if you in general
have
any major questions about c plus plus or
want to look for some
documentation i like this page you can
also look at specific
versions of c plus and if you look at
anything in particular you can switch
between different versions tells you
which headers finding
this is kind of the definitive site for
learning this stuff
let's look at a quick polymorphism and
we'll see that they have a book
i didn't know about this book thing
that's new so that could be really handy
if you want to get ahead
just go through that book but what i've
noticed personally is
it's really hard to read just this dry
info
about this this kind of stuff sometimes
so it often helps to have a bit of a
project
and then look at it from there well this
uh this site isn't so much to teach
it's more of a reference guide so there
might be better for teaching but if you
have any questions on any of this
stuff you can type in here so for
example what if we
type in type id so we want to learn more
about that we can go look at the type id
operator and see how it works
another thing you can also do for the
type id operator is you can just type it
in
and see what happens basically so okay
let's uh
let's go here we have type id right here
let's go follow which i believe is f12
uh there might be an option with the
right click i'm not sure i'm not seeing
here
but p catter okay so we want to if we do
like p header here i think no that's not
it
yeah that's not it either okay so i
guess it's just f12 f12 kind of follows
the code
so if you put your cursor on it and
press f12 there might be a better way
leave comment for sure you can uh you
can often go to it but we can't go to
this one
because it's in the standard template
header so what we want to do
is go to this header and you can press
f12 on this standard header it doesn't
seem to like
to follow this one let's see if we can
follow a string yeah we can follow the
string
i'm not sure why it's not wanting to
follow that it generally should as long
as it's illegal
header type info not found in our
current paths
so let's look again see if we can find
out anything all right type
type id type id operator type id with an
expression
all right very good and it should say
what header it's defined in
it doesn't really say here type in
header type
okay part of the type support
image type info yeah i mean earlier
i was able to go into this so i think
this right now is just above a visual
studio you should be able to follow it
i was definitely looking at it earlier
so visual studio
is a little awkward sometimes with the
way it tries to help you you know it's a
love hate relationship
uh it's better to at least have the
option at least most the time when it's
working properly than not because as
you've seen with all the squiggling and
stuff
most of the time they've been pretty
accurate i hope this soap
helps you uh understand inheritance a
lot more
and uh i would say just practice do
something like this
with a main play around and kind of see
what you can do
so you can get your things to work this
is something that's done all the time
in a lot of different software
especially games and stuff
yeah just being able to to derive
derived types
is something that can really scale ahead
some of the things you can
accomplish with programming definitely
good to know all right i'll see in the
next one hopefully you guys found this
helpful matt
kotek tutorials over and out and if you
want a lot more episodes like this and
want me to keep making them consider
signing up over on my patreon page or
supporting somehow
even just leaving a like or comment
helps a ton but uh yeah the more support
i can get the more i'll do stuff like
this
thanks guys see you next episode peace
[Music]
out
[Music]
[Music]
you